- [Mark] All right, Adriana.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Adriana, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Long Beach.
- [Mark] Long Beach? And
tell me about your family,
your had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- My dad wasn't around, he, he basically
left my mom when she was pregnant with me.
And I grew up with my
parents, my grandparents.
- [Mark] So your grandparents
raised you mostly?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And how was your childhood?
- My childhood? I, I was
living a good childhood
with my grandparents, my mom,
she was working all the time
and when I hit 16, that's
when I moved back up
from Northern California
to Southern California,
back to Long Beach and
just stay with my mom.
And she would always be
partying and shit like that.
And I would always be home by myself.
She was drunk all the
time, so I just ended up
you know, going out, doing
my thing, hanging out
with like, guys that were
like, 20 older than me and.
- [Mark] And you were how old?
- I was 16
- [Mark] 16?
- Yeah, and she had a drinking problem.
And when she met my,
my stepdad now my, my,
her new husband, they would always fight
and they would get abusive
and I wouldn't wanna be home.
I ended up getting pregnant
at 18, I had my daughter
when I was 19, well, almost 19.
A week before my 19th
birthday and I ended up,
you know giving her up for adoption
and my baby daddy, he wasn't wanting
to do nothing with the
baby until I told him
I was gonna give her up for adoption.
And she told, he told me that
he was gonna fight for her.
I had the baby and I tried,
I tried an open adoption.
And we were at before he, right before
the deadline for the
adoption to be finalized, he,
he signed over his, he signed over
saying that he won the
fight for the custody.
So he ended up winning custody.
I ended up going back, living with my mom
cause I got, when I got pregnant
I left with my grandparents
back in my grandparents
cause my mom didn't want
anything to do with me.
So I went back to my grandparents
and my baby daddy got full custody
and I didn't wanna be
back at my mom's house
but I had no choice.
So, and it got so bad to the point
where I ended up leaving again.
And I mentioned guy on that
introduced me to crystal.
And I ended up getting hooked on that.
And as time went by, my addiction got bad
and it made me not be around my daughter.
It made me just not wanna
do nothing with my family.
I ended up on Skid Row and
I just trying to do anything
possible to make money.
I had got in a car accident
last, about a year ago.
I was going on a year next
year, last year in May.
And I flew out the car and I fell,
I fell asleep and the guy who was driving,
fell asleep too behind the wheel.
And next thing you know, I, I'm on,
I'm on the ground and I'm waking up
and I'm asking the guy, can
you put me back in the car?
Like, can you stop screaming?
He said, the car was flipped over.
And I was so out of it
that I asked him, huh?
Can you put me back in the car?
And then he said, no, the
car is flipped over it.
I'm like really? And I fell back to sleep.
That, around that time, I didn't know
I got into a car accident, I went,
when I went to the hospital, the nurse,
when I woke back up,
the nurse told me I got
to a car accident and
I was, I was shocked.
I was like, what? And
the guy went to jail.
He waited for the
ambulance to come get me.
And he walked to the trailer
park, the trailer park,
it was in the middle of the desert.
And the trailer park was
about a mile or two away.
And there was nothing around, so he walked
to go get help and came and
meet the ambulance back.
And I had died, and I see my grandpa
that passed away a couple
of years before that.
And I seen his dad and they told me that
you have no, you you
still have time on this,
you still have things you got not to be,
to be, you got things to be done still.
And then next thing you know, I wake up
and the guy screaming, and I'm just like,
I'm cold, can you come back in the car?
And it was crazy.
- [Mark] So you feel like you died?
- Yeah, I I've, I did die,
I died and I came back.
God gave me another chance
to live on this planet.
So I'm just trying to find my purpose.
- [Mark] How was death?(laughing)
- How was death? It was kinda, it was,
it was kinda cool, I
mean not, not kinda cool,
but like you think it's
a dream when you die
you don't think it's
real like you just think
it's a dream, like.
- [Mark] How long, how long
did this last you think?
- Lasted like, maybe like 10, 15 minutes.
And how I knew that it
was, that I had died
cause this little girl, got into,
this little girl got
ran over like probably
like a mile from where I was at.
And I seen on a news on
the Facebook news that
there was a girl that got
hit, a baby that got hit
with, by a hit and run
driver that didn't know
that they hit something and
they cause they just kept going.
And when I died, I seen this little girl
a lot going into like, you know
going into the, going to
like a meet with two people.
And I couldn't see the
people, I just felt them.
And I just knew that,
like I just knew that,
it was like, it was just, it was,
it was, it was, it was cool, it was cool.
The little girl she went up and I seen
she had like the most
beautiful wings ever.
And she went up with the two people that
that walked into her and I sat there
and it was like and I
was thinking to myself,
like, why can't I go?
I felt kinda like sad
a little bit, and I see
my grandpa and I looked
at him and I could tell it was my grandpa.
Cause it was like a
younger version of him.
And he had looked at me
and then I heard a voice
say you still got things to be done.
You need to go back.
- [Mark] So you're,
you're, you're now in hell,
here in Skid Row?(Laughing)
- So I'm back over here
on Skid Row and, yeah.
- [Mark] How long have you been here?
- Two years.
- [Mark] Two years?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what is your
drug now? Still, Crystal meth?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how are you
supporting yourself now?
- I get a monthly check
and then I've been working.
I've been partially
getting money training.
I've been doing anything possible.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Including doing what
a lot of the girls will do for money?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Dating guys and stuff like that?
- [Mark] Yeah, has that
been dangerous for you?
- Yeah, I got into a couple of scenarios
in my life before I got into one scenario
where I got locked in the trunk of a car
and I was trying to get out
and the guy was not letting me out.
He told me to walk and I told him
I wasn't gonna walk, I didn't wanna walk
the streets and he
said, well, if we don't,
if you don't walk then
I'm gonna beat your ass
because he owed me some money.
And I was like, okay so I
lied and he dropped me off.
I went the other way and he found me
locked me in the trunk
and then he told me,
well, we're gonna try this again,
this time he had the walk with me.
So I was kinda, by the
way, eventually, and yeah
I didn't fuck with him ever since,
but I got myself in a couple of scenarios,
but I'm smart now, I don't, I,
I was dumb back then, I was.
- [Mark] Are you more careful now
with the guys that'll pick you up?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What, what have you learned?
- What have I learned?
- [Mark] I mean, like
what, what, what kind
of guy will you not get in a car with?
- I wouldn't get, I mean, I wouldn't
get in the car with just any guy.
I mean, if I knew him, I probably
would fuck with him,
but if I don't know him
and he's like been stalkerish, I won't,
I won't, I would just look
at him and just walk away.
- [Mark] Do you have any
contact with your mom still?
- Yeah, he, she's with my, my baby now.
She ended up buying my,
you know, her, my mom
her and her, my stepdad
are raising my kid.
- [Mark] Oh, they are?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So do you see your
daughter sometimes though?
- Yeah, next week is her birthday.
So she'll be eight years old.
I have an eight year old little girl.
- [Mark] And what keeps
you from getting your life
together and going back, you think?
- I'm trying to get my life together,
honestly, I'm trying
to save it for a place.
I mean, it's kind of
hard with the, with the
the rent and it being so high
and, but I'm almost there.
- [Mark] Tell me about
quitting crystal meth.
Does that seem like a possibility for you?
- Yeah, it really is cause I wanna be
more of a mom to my kid, I wanna be,
I don't wanna live like this, like,
I've been doing this way too long
and I wake up and I'm,
and I'm like 27 years old.
I'm still young, I could,
I could change my life.
- [Mark] Absolutely.
- Yeah, and when I see
other people out here
that are like older and shit like that,
it just makes me be like,
I don't wanna be like that
when I'm, you know and
it's true what they say
it's harder when you get older,
so, I need to get my shit and get,
trying to be serious about my shit now,
cause I wasn't serious before,
I would just fucking
bullshit and playing around
saying I was, you know,
I need to get on my shit
I need to get on my shit and now I'm like,
damn, I'm like 27 years
old, and I seen like
all my other friends that,
they got their shit together
and it makes me like, like
I need to get my shit together, because.
- [Mark] Is there anything about the way
you were brought up, you think
that maybe took you down this path?
- I think, seeing my mom, you know
like getting drunk and
partying and shit like that
it kinda like pushed me to, you know
not be home and not be, you know, go out,
me going out till three in the morning
and then having to go to the school
as a junior in high
school at seven o'clock.
And the last two years of my high school
I didn't go to school, I
mean, I went to school,
but I didn't go to my classes.
So it was like, I was addition in school
which was kind of stupid,
cause like, if, if I'm
if I'm not even going
to school at all, I mean
going to my classes, why be in school?
- [Mark] How far did you go in school?
- I did all four years, but
I failed two, two years.
So I would have to take
them two years of school.
- [Mark] And how do you think your life
on the streets has changed you?
- It made me realize a
lot of real shit, be,
like if you don't get up, get your ass up
and work and you know,
do something to make,
get some money, you ain't,
you ain't gonna have nothing.
And that's for like, not just people
out on the street, that's
for like everybody,
if you don't get your, if you don't get up
and get a job or like do
something with yourself, you,
you ain't gonna be, like,
how are you gonna eat?
I mean, how is your vibe, like, its.
- [Mark] And where are you staying now?
- Right now, I'm in,
I'm staying in my car.
- [Mark] So you have a car?
- Yeah, I have a car.
- [Mark] It's better than
tent, I guess, right?
- Yeah, I stayed in
tents before, first time
I stayed in the tent, I would just like,
Oh my God, this shit is
crazy, like, I'm in a tent,
I've never lived like that before,
so I've taken myself way, way, way down.
- [Mark] Is this a, is
this the lowest point
of your life right now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah?
- I was brought up with everything
and anything you could think about
anything I wanted, I had it,
my grandparents spoiled
me and I just like,
when my grandpa passed
away, it fucked me up.
Cause he was like my dad,
so I distanced myself
from my family a lot and my family
and I aren't close as we used to be.
I missed out on so many things already
with my family just because of how,
when my grandpa died, it killed me.
Like it made me so
numb, I didn't even know
when the funeral was, I
just lost track of time,
I lost track of everything, so.
- [Mark] What emotions
do you deal with now?
- Just trying to kinda anxiety, anxiety,
and about, about trying to hurry up
and trying to get my shit together
because I wasted so much time early
and my daughter, you know, she be,
she be understanding more,
so it's like over here,
she's wondering why my
mommy is not around.
- [Mark] Does she ask you?
- No, not really, my mom, I think my mom
is telling her like your mom's down around
cause she's doing other things.
I think at this point, my, my daughter
she's smart, she's smart like she got
like her little attitude, she's smart.
I don't know how my
daughter looks at me really.
And I think that's what
makes me more kind of,
kind of sad in a way, cause I don't know
how my daughter looks at me.
She calls, she calls me
mommy, but she knows,
she, she knows that,
she feels like her mom
is my grandma, I mean, my mom, my mom,
my mom is her mom, so I don't think
she really understands
like the meaning of a mom,
like the def, like, I think
he's confused in a way,
cause she, she calls me mom,
but she calls, she, she,
my, my mom, my mom is
more like of her mom.
So she feels more like, okay, my mom is
my mommy is not really my mom.
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm sure she's confused.
- Yeah, and that's what kind of
makes me upset and kind of kills me.
- [Mark] Is crystal
meth hard to stop using?
- A little bit, I mean, I have,
I have my days where I be
sober but as soon as I see
somebody that's got a pipe, I'm like
I only think about it, I just be like,
Hey, I'm like, let's get high now.
So it's kinda, it's
hard, I know I can do it.
It just I'm dealing with like a whole lot,
a whole lot of other things, so sometimes
I just give up, so I'm trying
to get my life together.
- [Mark] What emotions is being separate
from your child, bring up?
- The fear of her, not wanting
to, to like the fear of not
of her not wanting to,
anything to do with me
because I haven't really
been around like as much
as I used to be around and so it's kinda,
its kinda hard because I
don't want her growing up
and have, and have her
feel like what I felt
from my mom when I was
growing up and just not
just feeling like, like she don't know me.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Like she sees me, she knows me
but she don't know me as you know her mom.
And I feel kind of like, I, I pray that
I get another chance, you know,
I've been a mom, you know, I pray
I get another baby, but I get pregnant
by a good man and I can have another baby
and doing all over again.
But the last time I got pregnant
I got my tube busted and I didn't know
I was pregnant and so when
they did emergency surgery,
they found a baby, that
was, I think like 14 weeks,
Inside of me, they took out my tube,
they took out the baby and
now I have like 40% chance
of being pregnant again, so my lifestyle
has really like, just
made me like go down that.
- [Mark] But you have a child.
- I have a child.
- [Mark] You could be with her right now.
- Yeah, the only problem is my mom.
She, she still be doing her drinking.
My stepdad does her drink the drinking
and I can't deal with that shit,
I can't deal with him,
he was talking to me,
talking, putting holes in my walls
because they're fighting,
and then the next day they're good,
and then the following
day, they are at it again.
Like who wants to be around that?
- [Mark] Yeah, did you feel
like you were loved as a child
by your parents, your
mom or your grandparents?
- By my grandparents? Yeah, my mom? Yes.
But mom had a drinking problem
and she just couldn't see what
what the lifestyle she was living in
and the things she was
doing was affecting me.
If I didn't have to feel
like I couldn't come home
and the feeling of not wanting to be home,
I don't think I would
have ever done drugs.
I don't think I've ever
would've met that guy
who introduced me to crystal
and next thing you know,
I'm like doing crystal,
don't, don't even know
what the fuck, the the, the high was like
until I'm like for days and I don't know
what the fuck I'm doing.
And it was like, I had
a cousin that overdosed
on drugs when he was 17
and I was 14 years old.
So when, when he died, I, it took,
it took me to the point where
I didn't wanna do drugs.
I thought drug addict were disgusting.
I never thought I'd be a
drug addict or deep into it.
- [Mark] And having gone
through all this, what,
what's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- The most important lesson I learned
is life itself, it's a lesson.
Everything you go through for a reason
but at the same time, you gotta,
you gotta choose the right, you know,
the right path because when I got into
that car accident, it made me really,
it made me think that like, you know
after I woke up and I, you know
I woke up and I got to, I
got in the car accident,
it made me realize like, death is,
you can, death is real, and when you die,
you're gonna be, you're
gonna be welcomed by,
by this figures, and you're
either gonna go to hell
or you're gonna to
heaven, or you might get,
you might get another
chance and be looking like
me and get told that you're gonna go,
you gotta go back, I never thought
that I would have died and got turned
around, I had to go back.
- [Mark] But this is probably not the life
that you were supposed to come back to?
- No, I was kind of sad
that I didn't get to go back
with my grandpa and the little girl
but let me tell you that
little girl was so happy.
she was so happy it made
me, it made me smile.
And I thought it was all
a dream at, at first,
I didn't know I died when I died.
I just put the pieces together
and I just felt in my heart,
like, Oh my God, like I,
cause who survives an accident,
the car flips over, I fly out the window.
Who's gonna stay asleep through all that?
Or who, who's who who's gonna like.
- [Mark] Did the driver survive?
- Yeah, he survived, he woke up,
when the car was rolling over.
So he woke up, I wasn't
on, I wasn't on anything
mean I was not no weed, no
fentanyl, no, no nothing.
I was knocked the fuck out.
I didn't have a seatbelt on, but luckily
I just got a broken
collarbone and my, my finger,
my hand was fucked up,
but, and I got released
from the hospital that same day.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah, yeah, I was really confused.
I'm getting, the nurse wakes me up
and she goes, yeah, do you have anyone
you could call because
you're getting released now.
I'm like, what happened? I don't even know
what the hell happened, she's like, well,
the car rolled over and
you flew out the window
and, and you got in a car accident.
Am like what? I started boiling and I knew
I hadn't had no pain
in my body, no nothing.
I just felt like just the thought,
later on, I put the pieces together
and I remember like seeing
my, seeing the guy's dad
that I got into a car accident with,
seeing him, seeing his
dad, and I had never
seen his dad before, but his dad died
but I just knew it was his
dad, you just know when
when you die, you know
which, what, you feel it,
you might not know you
died, if you get a chance
to come back again, you
might not know you died,
but at first, but you just, you put pieces
together, yeah, and it's crazy.
- [Mark] I would, I would
have thought something
like that might've changed your behavior.
- Yeah, it did.
- [Mark] More than it has.
- It, it, it changed me
and how, it changed me,
it changed me wanting to fucking be more
on my shit and stop playing around
and stop fucking thinking that life
is a joke, life is just a game.
- [Mark] All right,
Adriana, thank you so much
for sharing your story and
I wish you the best of luck.
I hope you get back with your daughter.
- Mhmm, thank you.
- [Mark] I hope you put
down the, crystal meth.
- I will.
- [Mark] Thank you.